et tiens c'était quand la dernière fois
d'ailleurs c'était quand la dernière
fois quand tu vois c'est évidemment
c'est quoi c'est ayant parlé de rite aid
il ya 10 minutes vous faites ce que vous
voulez je ne veux pas dire sauf pour la
marche est une petite société comme le
dernier point a fool à un moment ça mais
on veut des latins on veut des dates
oui asada s'est élevé juillet 18 cents
il pleuvait turc arnaque aux c'est un
moment un moment on doit non merci
benjamin castaldi
ça va être la famille ce soir les séries
je vous dis hier soir non hier soir non
bâti avec qui très vite arrêté chez soi
oui et alors à bord il jouera contre
non non non non pas au débat et daniela
fauvet les malades enfin les malades
elle a mal au dos quoi bien faire peut
quoi quoi quoi non mais à sapiac ont
malheureusement valérie on peut pas je
vous veux enlever la perruque impasse
que vous sa part voilà non mais je vous
dis franchement je le dis pour vous moi
je m'en fous l'émission j'étais
peut-être un coup à nouveau mieux 1
voilà non je travaille pas donc oui un
petit bouton virginie qui a crevé à
lennon mais sont très contents que ce
soit la fin de l'émission que vous
voulez voilà jean michel mr bonsoir
[Rires]
même si je vais dire je le dis de parler
bien fort donc il fait le loup en bons
soient fouillés à michel 6 mars avec un
animal avec un humain je vais plus
ensemble normal hors wifi hier soir qui
m'applaudissent sa lettre à canning
j'étais à 21h10 aujourd'hui on se
demande bien maxime guînes l'année voire
d'une vidéo conjuguées à tristan bernard
effectivement on est même allé la voir
elle est naturel authentique
elle est drôle c'est que je sais que
jean luc l'adorent et c'est avec jean
volley-ball un excellent comédien on va
les pouvoirs c'est une empoisonneuse
aléas les vrais amis table monsieur oui
monsieur alors dernière fois il ya dix
minutes s'est passé tellement rapidement
que je m'en souviens plus tout faux
maintenant je vous demandais quand même
la bonne la meilleure benoît henry
d'anjouan de l'exercice il perdait
bonjour
étonnamment oui bien sûr toujours quand
la pluie taper sur les fenêtres ah ouais
elle un ouragan le taulard bon eh bah
oui ça c'est plutôt peur merci isabelle
morini-bosc merci d'état alors dimanche
dernier n'ont pas la cote a pas d'accord
à ce que pour les détails techniques
debout près de la douche mais non mais
je croyais je ne savais pas que c'était
que sexuel oui pardon j'ai une petite
soupe je dis que j'ai mangé une petite
soupe du coup ça n'est pas du tout
possible hommage à millicom et wav et
des couteaux alors et à votre dimanche
dernier oui à galin tous les week-ends
en semaine je planche sont patrick et
d'autres dans ce week-end ah ouais ben
patrick faites ce que vous voulez c'est
je ne touche aucun commentaire avec
bercy
bernard montiel il parlera forte
la dernière fois alors est ce que sait
faire la moue réjouir c'est pas pareil
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi c'est important d'assister à
sa fin de carrière en émission familiale
wii pas dire ça ou alors je suis
fédérateur non mais oui bah oui ça soit
oui alors jamais bien me disent merci
non mais bon on a dû à un dérapage et
c'est pourquoi des sanctions deviennent
durs est ce que c'est vraiment excusez
moi vous allez allez voir ici ici aux
eaux là
il est il est de plus en plus lourd
c'est ça le pire en fait je vous dire on
a tous posé cette question pour savoir
un truc c'était quand la dernière fois
daga corrèze son fonds peut on dire
bonjour à ce contenu
agathe bonsoir bonsoir série de revenus
assure j'ai envie de savoir
alors évidemment c'était quand la
dernière fois que quoi